i think
it's time to finish
house of ashes let's do it let's kill
that weird creepy little guy that just
came out
of rachel
but not before we inspect
whatever is glowing ever anywhere at all
times which there is nothing
why why why you want me to look at that
another one
it was a sound no i think it's okay
nothing okay cool
alrighty
is just all of them oh it's because
she's trying to find it maybe that's why
she's looking at it i didn't see where
it crawled to so
maybe that's what it is
surely there's a purpose to this surely
there is some reason
to be looking in all of these
is this someone already looked in
it's going great let's go great
okay not there i think i have just done
the rounds on looking in all of them
so
let's stop doing that shall we
maybe i didn't do this one
i don't know i'm so bad at navigating
just across the board terrible just not
not a skill i have
oh it's so nasty
[Music]
[Laughter]
yep on it but find
i it feel great about this why do we
need to pick it up on it
oh i hate that
oh i hate it
god
it seems dead
that's a lot of noise
i still don't feel like we have a plan
yeah what i'm saying
like those mounds are made of cocoons
thousands of them yep
yeah what about all the ones that aren't
there
i just don't really feel like we're
prepared for this
[ __ ] we're hatching
yep
we gotta move
quick
okay listen up
we've been hit hard tonight
we lost brothers
but now
it's time to get some payback
once you plan charges on as many of
those clusters as possible and then
detonate them remotely second those
charges all last to the exit flux is on
our side we'll do more than fry if
you've got is the exit ready jason where
is the guy here at least we'll take some
of those bastards down with us
okay
who's going to place the dynamite
um
all right [ __ ] it i'll do it
you're crazy we'll do it together nah
the more of us down there the more
chances we'll get he's right but nick is
still my favorite detonator if i don't
make it nick hear me out
if i don't make it andy's injured i want
you to blow those charges
just don't go getting trigger happy on
me
every step of the way you picking radio
contact i prefer anybody else's guys no
radio signal well i like something
[ __ ] go up
you hit that detonator be quick and be
safe
hear me buddy
okay
i still don't know what the plan is
after this though like okay so you're
gonna blow up an ancient
structure
which
seems like a bad idea
um
and then what we don't have an exit
like literally what is the plan
this is interesting okay
what
i can't make it out
oh i'm i'm celine
that's interesting okay
didn't want me to do anything else with
that um okay so i'm just gonna keep
looking at nick where'd he go
there
there's one ahead of him
okay coons are hatching ahead of you you
gotta move fast where where the [ __ ] did
he go
i got so nervous
first dynamite is down over oh no
this is this is a lot of responsibility
which way left foot right
this [ __ ] guy
i wonder what breed he is
like what species is he
[Applause]
oh
that's very stressful my stomach is
panicked
please go away
i would like to live
he shouldn't have gone out and he's
injured
like literally anybody else
send eric out we hate him send him out
see if i can
there's so much screaming oh [ __ ]
it's getting kind of hairy down there
brother why don't you ditch the rest of
those charges and head back look at that
man
it's the motherboard
it's too far
oh [ __ ]
i want him to retreat
but he would
advance i'm going for it
he would do that
i may have just killed him
which sucks but i feel like that would
be the move that he in this position
would be making it's too easy
oh no
what is it
there are too many
he said that man it might be
sweet baby maybe we can distract them
wait
what will warning him do now
is no way out
that is
hey how's he looking up there bad dude
he's looking bad
you know he won't make it
let him finish his work
you won't even feel it when it comes
i thought we'd tell him
it's clear nick
you're all clear
why have we done why have we done that
to him
there's that tell again they're on to me
aren't they
oh he repeats himself that's right
like i said no one's got the ball to
touch him
i still think that's what he would have
done and if he dies like this
that's the hero's death
he's going to be happy about that
i don't think he would have just dropped
it i don't buy it
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay
the light is making that extra hard what
the [ __ ]
my palms off
jesus christ
[Music]
is
oh yeah if you're quiet
[ __ ] this guy
this [ __ ] nerd with his butt teeth i
can say that i had buck teeth real bad
as a kid it's still quite large
but less buck toothy
is that intention to
blow them away
oh it was to detonate
i don't buy that he's dead
yes that's a large explosion but in what
world are you not gonna show me that
i'm gonna buy it
i'm sorry no it's not enough
it's not enough
no
i'm sorry there is no way it wouldn't
show us his gross dead body
[Music]
he's okay
this is how you die
i may have made it
well what happened to
bucks from the door
bearing 320.
but
i'm injured i need help
and i love nuts historically a huge fan
sergeant
he
sucks
[Music]
are you with
me nick
yes i mean the true hero of the video
game
yes
i got you i'm amazed by how invested i
am i care a lot about nick
people eric
rachel
jason
i like him a bit more
salimo nick
not having it i'm not having it
really dude you could have just maybe
tapped it a few more times
i still don't know what the exit plan is
you guys i still don't know what the
actual plan to get we're just getting
back in that [ __ ] elevator and just
like assuming
we can leave now there's an explosion in
the hollow underneath us in this ancient
area
like is that
the rationale
feels like this whole damn place again
to find godsend we could literally all
die
he's still alive
julie come in man are you there
i am surrounded
[ __ ] he's a dead man we need to go
no
no
semper fire whatever the [ __ ] it was
that he said
that man is not one eric go [ __ ]
yourself politely
you're wrong
salim is one of us now marines don't
leave their own behind you hear a
miscellaneous
tell
this is a lot of decision making that
i'm not confident in
you need to press something
it was just that one dude
oh there we go okay
cool
jason
jason
i love it
is that it are there more
mom spaghetti out here mom spaghetti
you know they don't do anything
you know that
come on
yeah
simplify that's what i said that's what
i said
i think i've only got like three
achievements
you have to go back and achieve it huh
oh man that was unfucking believable
those things were all over us
me and celine busted through them like
it was the last down of the goddamn
super bowl
it's cute it's cute
listen up
i'm not out of the woods yet
what i see in front of me
you're the best
[ __ ] that
best of the best
we will get home
i'm trying man i'm trying to do my best
here i'm trying
i feel like
i feel like
i'm worried about nick i'm worried about
the injury
and i'm wondering if maybe
the med kit should have been used on
nick but because i let saleem take
damage for rachel selim needed it but
maybe that one would be consequential i
don't know
i just feel like that probably
you could have healed me
because i had
[Music]
where are these ropes from and how do we
know they are of quality
what
have i forgotten something
the [ __ ] you got these ropes dude
nope
eric
come on
we go together
what are you looking at
what
okay what what what just happened
see this is what i was concerned about
again americans
sometimes blowing [ __ ] up isn't the best
call that's all i'm saying sometimes the
bad [ __ ] idea
especially
when you're trying to escape and the
ground below you is hollow
and very old
i love a cracked cough
[Music]
it looked like that throat was 100 isn't
going to fail
it's not going to work
because you you didn't even swing it
where was the momentum on that
my gosh did we get out
[Applause]
holy heck
[Applause]
did i save everybody who was savable i'm
not sure about clarice i don't know if
she could have been fixable with the uv
i think she was too far off
i don't think
merwin ever lived he was destined to die
because of the razor wire we made it
i may have saved everybody soak up those
rays guys i'm not confident it's
completely done though what are we gonna
fall back down or some [ __ ]
you're still with me buddy yeah i hope
he's okay
thank you i love my life
very [ __ ] ready to go home marines
here
just popping drop kick to coyote two
radio check over
this
[Music]
we got back up again
you beat the enemy
i forgot how bright it is yeah it's just
really bright i think those shepherds
are still around here
i can use a cold one
i must return home to my boy yeah
he must be worried about me
how long have they been down there
it does always say the time
[Music]
no
not again
[Music]
[Music]
this is how it happened the first time
right
sure of the defenses block is placed
down tight but i don't know if they all
just like disappear
when the eclipse ends
how long until the damn eclipse passes
they usually
we just need to hold out this is way too
long
you can't rush the damn moon
[Applause]
it's breaking inside
i feel like i'm still at risk of
everybody dying
it feels like i'm trying to protect
children
you're not taking it from me
no no
i'm not having it
take eric
take care
oh god
it really feels like you're like trying
to protect babies like they're really
stupid and they need a lot of help
everybody can die
and also
i think doing this correctly
on attempt one is pretty nuts before
last clip
anyone got any more bright ideas
like having everybody live
i would like to maintain
the win
players
where is the ammo
like them we can hold them off
if you say so
that's a good shot
[Music]
they don't like light or fire
okay rachel okay what's the plan rachel
here
[ __ ]
did i miss that
oh
i must have intense gamer face right now
hmm
i would also really like you to listen
they're so [ __ ] stressed
i almost missed that one
x is it too each i don't know it could
give me more
i don't know the rules oh foxy dude oh
my god
did i do it did the achievement spoil
but i did it okay
rachel has lived
here
i love this
i did it oh my god five characters
survived oh my god
my hands are so sweaty
the achievements kind of ruined that
that was done for me but that's okay the
eclipse also probably would have given
it away
oh my god
what does that mean like are they all
just dead now forever or what
there's probably there could still be
some in the cave
in theory
i need to see my boy
it's
probably not still his birthday that's
even it's
wait
give me your number
good luck brother we can hang out next
time i'm around with shane happy
birthday from me
let's get thank you jason
goodbye my friend
really makes you look at the sun
differently praise the sun indeed
he's so funny he tripped and fell in
that hole after all that
she couldn't help himself
they're all tired and hungry probably
dehydrated does stuff tea brain
where's the music ominous
it's a really pretty shot
[Music]
i'm happy for him
that was important to me accomplished
something good here today
there it's the assault team
yeah we've seen some [ __ ] we came out
here
she a red header is that blood i think
it's dried blood from that weird blood
cool
clear
nobody's going to take pictures or
anything we're not going to document
any of this isn't that like a thing in
the u.s
what
oh celine left i was like did nick die
in the house
no
um yeah isn't that a thing that they
would do would be like we should
probably get a report on these maybe
they'll come back
everybody needs
a lot everybody just needs a lot of help
except eric who's miraculously fine
[Music]
that was stressful that was stressful my
gosh
all five flames that was it then that's
the only ones who could have survived
the other three
joey
clarice the mind is its own we're never
gonna make it
and in itself can make a heaven of hell
a hell of heaven
bravo
it appears your charges have emerged
from their hell in one piece
although this ordeal
will continue to haunt them for the rest
of their life well you can't be like oh
good work but they have ptsd so maybe
they should have died
next encounter perhaps call their show
choose a story that's a little more
homely next time somewhere you'll be
guaranteed of a decent night's sleep
rest assured
wherever it is
you'll find it extremely hard to leave
until the next time
good day sir you know the way out
thank you for having me i appreciate it
um
eric sucks
very cool it was fun i had a really good
time it was a fun time
you're late and you look like [ __ ]
i just got off the red eye what's your
excuse
good flight oh [ __ ] movie [ __ ] meal no
leg room they grab me in the back
by the toilets
nice
coffee wasn't so bad though good [ __ ]
muffins did you read the brief on the
flight
how's it going with the analysis team
four of the isg units survived they're
being debriefed through here
shall we after you
and the entities
like nothing we've seen before this is
what i was hoping that somebody was
doing at some point you'd better kill
that you better kill that
first lieutenant
the best of the best huh or so they
advertised
[ __ ] now how many times do i have to
keep telling you the same damn story
i understand however sitcom needs to
iron out any irregularities such as the
whole [ __ ] thing was regular
such as why you allied with an enemy
combatant you aren't [ __ ] there those
things ripping us to shreds i don't give
a damn who it was we needed all the help
we could get
i stepped back into that hell to save
saleem and that man was with five of you
people semper [ __ ] fire
but i cannot i'm dying to meet this guy
imagine
in a situation like that that you want
trained to just
get out with as much help as you can by
the time the extraction team got here he
was gone
could be across the border by now sneaky
son of a [ __ ]
now i see why colchek enlisted his help
it wasn't that sneaky the analysis team
are still pulling specimens from the
site
it's carnage down there
they use dynamite
we don't know how they got their hands
on it no no no no no i'm done i told you
already it was a city a goddamn city
full of those things
there were cocoons down there [ __ ]
thousands of them yep
how many organisms were still alive down
there too many
oh for all her shake
you're [ __ ] burdened
this is like winterfold all over again
uh-huh
ah and here we have colonel eric king
our in-house genius he definitely got
more than he bargained for yeah known
weapons messenger everything you know
about biology just went up in smoke
these things they're advanced they're
stronger than us more intelligent than
anything in showers wanna get ahead of
this you need to start taking me
seriously none of us doubt the severity
of the situation colonel
a number of people have died i made it
out alive
and i'm gonna make sure those things
stay buried in that hellhole where they
belong
nice
let's move on to kayla's
i can hear it beeping and i don't know
if it's happening in the game or in the
real world
i think it's in the game
well
do you believe not positive
this is miller he'll be fully debriefing
you
debriefing
you need to get your damn priorities
straight
those things are still down there
what are you doing about them
there will be plenty of time to talk
things through right now i suggest you
count your blessings that you came
through the other side
well it's nothing short of a miracle
that you survived down there i learned
not to rely on anyone but myself
i was stronger than them all
we'll be back shortly strange take
rachel i don't know about that
are you still on for next sunday
it's definitely a scripted dialogue line
of i broke up with both of my boyfriends
and now i'm a strong independent
why would you want to
at least this one was localized
small blessings
so
what do you make of it all
doesn't matter what i think
only thing that matters is controlling
the flow of information
as far as the world knows
not a damn thing happened here
[Music]
it is to be expected i would think
um
all right that's it i guess
um i do want to look at
the achievements 250 of a thousand we
missing a lot every part of randall's
channel i never go through collective
space cheeks we're never doing that all
playable is cat all playable characters
dying in the finale oh that'd be easy
that's just
don't do the qt's
just one character survive
also that would be easy
eric and nick share a moment in the
elevator
i wonder what that requires
[Music]
choose only head decisions where
possible no not doing that no
no no
oh i could do that we cannot
finish the solo story
have i not done that
i have eric ignore the radio signal okay
[Music]
i could go through and grab some of
those yeah i think that i would probably
do that
on um a stream or through a twitch
stream where i catch up on some of the
the achievements that we missed
it was a fun time i don't know what it
means to be a killer
think of the most profound thing you've
ever done
the most beautiful thing you've ever
created
[Music]
and i promise you
it's nothing compared to watching the
life bleed out of someone
to see the fear in their eyes
to feel them point at you for release
to hear them pleading
begging
that's true art
that's when you have to be
an artist
[Music]
i've left my mark on the world
it's cool
have you
is that for the next one oh this is
season one finale
ah there you go
it's gonna be about a murderer i suppose
just like until dawn
very cool i'm down i'll i'll play
through that one too why not why not
the more the merrier
and i think that's probably it
that means it is it
good stuff thank you for joining me for
this uh wonderful playthrough everybody
and i will see you all next time